et stéphane sarrazin les enchères folle
folle folle comme par exemple ce lot de
quinze magnum de gros parents tout
vosne-romanée adjugé 1 millions d'euros
soit près de 45000 euros le litre
le montant total de la vente avoisine
les 30 millions d'euros pour un millier
de bouteilles des vins d'exception
provenant tous du domaine d'henri jahier
vraiment de la qualité au fil du temps
le célèbre vignerons bourguignons décédé
en 2006 avait accumulé tous ces témoins
de sa production dans sa cave pour
philippe charlot pain qui a côtoyé cet
artiste du vin la cote d' henri jayer
s'explique avant tout par son travail il
avait une philosophie une approche du
pinot noir exceptionnelle a touché très
sensuelle très délicat et pas maigre
salir les mains n'était pas maigre
il était fin élégant et maintenant on
retrouve aussi beaucoup de ses héritiers
viticulteurs vignerons qui font des vins
dans ce style là pour ce spécialiste du
vin l'adage ce qui est rare est cher ce
vérifie petites productions comme les
domaines de romanée conti ou leroy ou
plus de production du tout comme chez
henri jayer cette combinaison suscite
forcément langue ou mai
2 - de formidable dans le monde entier
et puis ce sont des petits volumes
une bouteille de romanée conti bonheur
maintenant il y en a six mille par an
pour le monde entier donc henri jayer
c'était la même chose il y avait très
peu de vin pour le monde entier et tout
le monde s'arrache les bouteilles selon
ce spécialiste cette vente n'aura pas
d'impact sur les prix des vins de
bourgogne
vous pouvez donc être rassuré il sera
encore possible de se faire plaisir un
coût raisonnable